so one of the funniest and most
interesting God of all theories that
I've heard so far is that Kratos is in
fact the world serpent as always of
these videos they're most likely be
spoilers so if you've not yet finished
the game and you know what the story
spoiled please click away now so it's no
secret that the world serpent and the
rest of Loki's children have caused a
bunch of confusion amongst most God of
War fans with the Tres being revealed as
Loki his children would have not yet
been born the v-world serpents presence
in the game is explained through the use
of time travel during a battle Thor it
fell down the branches of Yggdrasil and
was sent back in time whenever actually
directly told that your Magan is a child
of Loki or trace but when craters in a
trace first encountered the world
serpent it seems to already be familiar
with them now there are quite a few
things and even potential coincidences
that have led people to believe that
Kratos may in fact be the world serpent
sent back in time the physical
appearance of young Magan to being quite
an interesting point of comparison the
color of the world serpent itself is
something that many people may have
missed but I know firsthand when looking
into Norse mythology and you'll meet and
in particular I never really came across
any depictions of the serpent as being
white and it definitely does match the
skin of Kratos but if we look closer we
even see red markings on your money and
that resemble Kratos his tattoos what I
found to be quite amusing was that we
even see the world serpent rocking a
goatee
perhaps even a sly nod in the direction
of old-school Kratos
if we compare Kratos his eyes to the
eyes of the world serpent they do
somewhat seem familiar throughout the
game and in official artwork craters his
eye color does seem to change but I
caught several moments in a game where
his eyes have an almost golden glow very
similar to what we see once again with
the world serpent even if we ignore the
physical similarities and just put them
down to coincidence or perhaps even
Santa Monica Studios attempting to
create multiple points of discussion
there are also a few things that could
equate to this theory being correct what
I found most interesting was that the
end of the game when the panel in the
wall is revealed we see an image that
most people have assumed is the prophecy
of a trace killing Kratos but there are
a few other ways we can view this some
people have stated they believe this
image means father and son being bound
together in their journey if we want to
get a look closely we can see a trace is
breathing something into Kratos his
mouth which is also somewhat resemble
the coils of
snake perhaps this could symbolize a
trace turning his father into the world
serpent in order to save his life or
perhaps even out of anger we can't
really tell this may also give Santa
Monica studios another way to explain
the children of Loki instead of them
being born they could be transformed by
at Reyes if we take all of this into
consideration along with the fact that
the world serpent is quite familiar and
friendly towards it Reyes it's
definitely a fun theory to consider I'm
not entirely sure if I'm quite sold on
the idea of Kratos becoming a giant
serpent the lemon are you guys think had
you ever consider the similarities
between the two or do you think Kratos
could in fact be someone else in the
Norse pantheon let me know in the
comments below